I think it's finally about time we
talked about the elephant in the room
valerant Skins are kind of a scam
they're way too damn expensive are given
to us basically unfinished and even
predatory so how despite everyone
knowing this is Riot getting away with
it all right before we jump into it we
have another merch drop let's have a
look let's get one thing straight you
are the best [__] gamer on planet
Earth and I think it's time you started
dressing the part shift walking is for
cowards smash that W key and check out
the score Esports drop 2 available now
if you like the look at that check the
link in the description below the world
of in-game Cosmetics is a bit of a weird
one despite us constantly complaining
how every item is locked behind a pay
wall or some sort of randomized loot box
we can't help ourselves but throw money
at them the truth is no matter the title
most of us capital G gamers are absolute
freaks when it comes to our precious
Cosmetics head nor
head sing Flames sing Flames that's the
effect that's the
effect that being said as fanatical as
we can often be spend just a little bit
of time in the valerant community and
you'll notice that they're just a little
bit different about their skins in fact
they're just a little bit different
period on one hand valerant has been
able to grow this massive Community
that's as inclusive as it is diverse
which is insanely important for the
future of Competitive Gaming on the
other hand there's like this for every
kill you get I'll give you an
ooo all right bet oh my God I'm so
nervous
o o
listen Counter-Strike Apex OverWatch
every Community has its own quirks but
there's just something about valerent
that brings out the weirdness in us that
of course extends to the passion for
Cosmetics case in point this recent
Reddit post where a user asked what
knives in the game could be used to
spell out the word feet when slashing an
object because of course that's
something you need to know or how about
the fact that teammates will
legitimately ask you to drop skins so
that they can play with them coming from
Counterstrike this was pretty bizarre to
me sure sometimes people will ask to
have a look at your skins but it's
usually out of pure curiosity or even
admiration sure I would love to hold a
661 blue gem with four Titan holos but
I'm not about to start begging for it
every round because it's theirs not mine
hell if you look online you will see
plenty of posts from people complaining
about this trend some going so far as to
claim that teammates have thrown games
for not getting skins dropped for them
don't get me wrong Counter-Strike trolls
will throw a [__] match over these
smallest of inconveniences but they
would never stoop this low that could be
because Counterstrike Skins are just a
lot more personal in comparison to
valerant whether it's the pattern the
wear the float or the stickers you put
on it there's so much that goes into
deciding what type of skin you want and
Counter Strike and every Factor just
makes it more personalized with valerin
it sometimes feels like people want
skins just for the sake of wanting
them nah the Reaver is dog [__] dude
Reaver is straight dog
H uses that
up okay why don't you say that in the
first place now this isn't just me
[__] on valerent skins for the hell
of it because in fact most of them are
very cool sure some are a little
repetitive and others aren't for me but
valerant Skins are usually really
creative and can do things that other
games just can't which is why it's such
a shame that they're kind of a scam now
I know what you're saying Devon all
Cosmetics are scams and yes big true but
there is a certain amount of shadiness
that comes with valerant for starters
they are expensive as Fu for a premium
bundle it's almost like a 100 bucks
Canadian and to make matters worse you
can't even just buy the exact amount of
in-game currency you need to buy them so
you're usually forced to purchase more
than you actually need yes there are
certain skins in Counterstrike that cost
about a billion dollars that
99.99% of the player base won't ever be
able to use but at the same time
Counterstrike also has really good skins
that are just a couple bucks even
sometimes cents and you can make them
even better by adding stickers and I
know it gets set all the time but it
Bears repeating you can always resell
your items in valerant everything just
feels overpriced and that is made even
worse by the fact that you don't even
get the full product when you buy it so
you pay almost $100 for a premium bundle
but then all of the color variations and
animations that are associated with that
bundle are locked behind yet another
type of currency how do you get get that
second type of currency well you either
grind it out of the battle pass most of
which is locked behind the paid version
of it or you buy it outright what makes
this even more insane is that Riot
already prices these skins based on how
involved they are skins that have
animations sound effects or other
variants are placed in a higher tier by
Riot so why the [__] do I then have to
spend even more money once I already
paid extra for it hell even if you had a
skin that you wanted and were willing to
spend the money on Good Luck because
valerant decided that it also needed to
be a gacha game where you need to check
back into your shop daily to see when
your item pops up and listen I'm not
just complaining for the sake of it
because I'm coming from Counterstrike
some of the most outspoken voices on
this topic are people that have been in
the community since day one the price of
skins the radi night system the rotating
shop every other post about this game is
discussing these problems and it's been
like this since launch but that also
means if people have been complaining
for this long things are likely not
going to change the unfortunate truth is
that whatever Riot is doing is working
and the same story goes for basically
every other game that does similar [__]
like this it would take nothing short of
a revolution to actually change things
and at the rate people buy skins I
wouldn't hold my breath that being said
all of these issues we discussed have
been having an effect on my personal
enjoyment with valerent and that's what
I'm going to leave you with today I am a
man of Simple Pleasures I like westerns
so when the Neo Frontier skin bundle
came out I thought to myself hey I might
finally buy something unfortunately for
me this was at the tail end of it being
released and by the time I logged in it
was gone and I [__] you not I actually
stopped playing for a while because of
this and to this day I get a little
salty about it and think why am I
grinding if I don't have the Skins I
want what more is there to this game and
it got me thinking about a few things
first if skins have this big of an
effect on my psyche maybe I should seek
professional help but more broadly as
[__] up as this entire cos medic
industry is are expensive as skins
better than none at
all my only like you kids these days
won't remember is like the old like how
skins used to be and how actually like
lucky we kind of have it like yeah [__]
super expensive now but back in like the
Nexon days of like maple story when you
would like get your parents credit card
and put in those wacky numbers and like
you would get a bamboo hat in maple
story but you would only get it for 30
days and then you'd have to buy it again
that was all the items were just on like
cool Downs basically that's why